القرار الغربي الامريكي ليس معزولا عن
التطورات على الجبهات في اوكرانيا خصوصا
ان ريهان الروسي في الايام الاخيره تركز
على تحويل معركه سوليدار الى نقطه تحول
لصالحه في مسار الحربه فاسيطره على صديدار
تعني فتح الطريق للجيش الروسي المسنود
بمرتزقه والقوات الانفصاليه المواليه نحو
باخمود بوصفها اهم اهداف موسكو في مقاطعه
دونياسك بالنسبه لاوكرانيا فان خساره طبخ
موت تعني ان خساره خط الدفاع الاهم عن
باقي المناطق التي لا تزالوا تحت سيطرتها
في دنياك وعلى راسها كراماتسك لذلك فان
الجيش الاوكرانيا وبعد اقراره اخيرا
بالخساره الائمه في سوليدار يريد الاستماع
بالدفاع عن موقعه في الشرق حتى لو تحول
المشهد هناك الى معارك استنساف داريات دون
تحقيق مكاسب ميدانيه ولذلك جاءت الضغوط
الغربيه على اكياس بضرو تغيير التكتيكاتها
القتاليه والتوجه نحو جبهات الجنوب حيث
يمكن ومن خلال الاسلحه الثقيله النوعيه
التي ينتظر ان تحصل اوكرانيا عليها من
الحلفاء من شن حرب خاطفه
تستولي خلالها على مدن مهمه لا سيما في
جنوب دونياس وسباروديا وخرسون نجاحه
اوكرانيا في تحقيق تقدم الجوهريا على
شبهات الجنوب سيشكل وفق خبراء عسكريين
غربيين تحديا صعبا للجيش الروسي مع اقتراب
الخطر من شبه جزيره القمه وقد يجبرها على
تغيير خطتها في الشرق خصوصا اذا ما نجح
الجيش الاوكراني في استعاده مناطق الجسر
البري بين روسيا والقمه